you are married to a spy kid  [Applause]  [Music]  I'm married to  now  how did you meet him may I ask oh  there's a couple stories but um the  first one ever I was a I was like 18  years old as a baby songwriter out here  in LA and I was at a songwriter  Hollywood party and he crashed it with  two of his friends and I was like Spy  Kids is here and I I went right to him  and I I usually my fangirl so hard and I  don't say anything but I went right to  him was like are you spy kids and he was  like yeah and was really nice and then  two years later I became a famous pop  star and I was friends with Chloe Moretz  and she I was like I want a nice guy I  just I'm sick of all these mean guys I  want a nice guy and she's like my best  friend's the nicest guy and then we went  on a double date and we've never been  apart ever since